the i-team with information you will  only get tonight on the valley's news  leader new numbers show kovid 19  was the third cause of death in nevada  for all of last year  nearly 3 500 people in our state from  covid  you can see heart disease remaining the  number one cause of death  followed by cancer at number two las  vegas councilwoman olivia diaz says  we cannot let our guard down let's make  sure we're doing our part let's make  sure  i mean we've learned from all of this  experience  that it is in our hands to protect  ourselves and to keep our family safe  more than 31 thousand people in nevada  died last year  covid19 is responsible for 11 percent  of those deaths